[Music]
Europe is renowned for its mid laners
from the Great's of the games early days
you can see there's giving in that is
definitely uphold the Nexus he's trying
to do it
the beta starts going to defend them in
the face
[Applause]
to more modern stars like power of evil
or febiven so the visits into the jungle
not as fruitful that there's the death
bar coming in and will it be enough the
poem the ignites
[Applause]
and though there have been times where
their strength wavered there has always
been another generation of great
European mids and in some ways it feels
like it has all been building up - he's
a mechanical genius I've already made
the statement before that I think he's
basically the most mechanically gifted
player we have ever sent out of Europe
he's not afraid to do what's unexpected
the statement before that caps can play
everything I did not expect a mid lane
Fame to be a thing that's crazy and he's
still young caps has been a hair's
breadth from glory and he's not done
chasing it this is his story
[Applause]
[Music]
Rasmus caps Winther was born on November
17th 1999 in Denmark to a family that
embraced videogames
his older brother Christopher around a
decade his senior often played games
while caps was a kid and caps was
entranced caps his brother played dota 2
at a high level under the handle rise on
a slew of teams between 2012 and 2017
and while his brother travelled to
compete in tournaments caps was grinding
soloqueue in a different MOBA altogether
League of Legends it was clear from the
beginning that caps was a talent in mid
laner and in January 2015 a 15 year old
cap signed within nigma eSports a small
multi gaming org based in Finland though
enigma played mostly in small European
tournaments caps began to make a name
for himself for flashy soloqueue plays
and though it's not clear exactly when
he picked up this nickname caps his
prowess in soloqueue led some of
Europe's high yellow players to dub him
baby faker I don't remember exactly how
it started but I believe it was when we
were playing softer the higher LoZ knew
was playing together and and as many
know when you someone does something
cool something fancy people will say oh
you're Vega and then because of my age I
think people start saying like oh baby
faker
of course when faker came to Europe for
the 2015 League of Legends World
Championship he encountered a young caps
in soloqueue and after the young mid
laner sprinkled a little BM into all
chat the greatest player to ever touch
the game showed caps what a full-grown
mid laner could do
caps bounced between orgs in early 2016
playing in online tournaments and honing
his skills in soloqueue eventually he
signed with nerve
midway through the summer Challenger
split it's gonna be nerve with wicked in
the top plane momentum in the jungle but
the new players here caps upset and
nukes a lot all coming in thought enough
to see if they can shake up that lineup
a little bit
capsules edition was not enough to make
up for a weak start and nerve finished
the season in last place though caps did
manage to put up a few highlights caps
is coming in from the backline - Sarah
is on to jokah and the teleporter
nervous kaze because it's going solo it
routed in place by nuke so like the heel
comes up very very good thanks to
subjugate the caps get to kill the
jugger the celestial expansion is
ticking damage away that's a triple on a
rally at Seoul but in the wake of the
challengers split caps moved a little
further from home signing with Turkish
law team dark passage in July to play in
their summer split playoffs with caps
and fellow European junglers Dirk see on
the roster dark passage won the TCL
playoffs
the wind would have given caps of a
chance to play in the international
wildcard tournament for a potential spot
at Worlds but he was too young to attend
the event still his performance in
Turkey coupled with his raw mechanical
talent was enough to attract the
attention of a major European org
looking to refresh its roster fnatic I'm
probably would have stayed in school
maybe I don't I don't know what would
happen if I didn't join phonetic
maybe I gens another team but I'm not
really sure capsules place on the team
was revealed on a stream in December
2016 and the initial community response
was mixed Capps was a promising
up-and-coming player and a soloqueue
star but for one of the region's most
famous teams he was an unknown quantity
fnatic for their part were in a bit of a
rebuilding period 2016 had been g20 in
Europe and for the organization that had
once dominated Europe a new roster with
promising talent was an attempt to
reclaim their throne but the first split
of 2017 did not belong to fnatic they
placed third in their group in the
regular season and managed a playoff run
to semi finals where they lost to
eventual champions g2 eSports
it wasn't a return to form exactly for
the old kings of Europe but a
third-place finish was a promising start
and though reckless and brazo were a big
part of their playoff success caps was
beginning to make a name for himself in
the old Grand Arena that is the European
mid lane cap took a lot of damage
remember earlier he used that ultimate
just to clear the way for the instant
cleanse running for his going the
exhaust from caps just saved the day
he built a reputation as an aggressive
laner and also for picking some unusual
meds from his pocket aurelion sol - kale
to Camille but he's in the ultimatum
right now blocking damage they flash in
reckless throws down the change of
corruption and it's gonna be caps that
follows through that's a lot of pics
that I could in certain scenarios and I
just feel like I am I feel confident
enough that I can pull it off even if I
don't have too much price on it and I
think a lot about less they realized
that they cam is good in those
situations but they maybe don't have the
same confidence maybe they are more
confident in like a smaller chairman
pool and somebody approaches a lot of
times right but I'm more like anything
heading into the summer split fnatic may
not have been favourites against the
likes of g2 eSports but they had a shot
and the regular season showed promise
once again
caps was a big part of his team success
and once again he did it on some
unconventional champions it's been
something he's been playing quite a bit
of especially that Corki so that's K
table mid lane alright fnatic they're
the ones to take that away that's gonna
be caps he's he's the kind of guy to do
that kind of stuff yeah yeah why not
after a turbulent spring split fnatic
we're sitting in first place in Group A
by the end of the summer ahead of both
g2 and misfits obviously based on
phonetics been in arguably the best team
in Europe expected to make finals is
that extra pressure is that really
difficult
I mean it definitely gives pressure but
I like pressure I think and as a child
Finley when I joined the team my goal to
wealth netic is to in world so yeah
fnatic entered their semi-final match as
heavy favorites against misfits
but misfits were not the same team that
they had been in the regular season and
the series did not go as fnatic expected
they looked for brock's unfortunately
he's not going to be able to do a whole
lot more without that glacial prison
however the mini waves no longer bear
and empower that's a little bit of sweat
off fnatic sprout but they might just
lose to the hands of misfits and for
this team things are looking oh so good
as they close out fnatic Wade Bosh down
and it's a date with destiny in Paris
after a split full of promise it was a
disappointment fnatic didn't win the
summer split they didn't even make it to
the finals of course their season wasn't
over fnatic took down h2k in a close
third-place match that earned them the
top seed to the regional gauntlet there
they would once again faced off against
h2k and this time captain company
secured a spot at Worlds in dominant
fashion caps he was confident going into
this game here and this was one of the
most one-sided few fives I have seen in
a long time here in Europe fnatic made
it out of the play in stage at Worlds
2017 fairly convincingly but it would be
anything but smooth sailing from there
in the first week of the group stage
disaster struck whether it was nerves on
the part of rookies on the world's
biggest stage unforced errors or
something else altogether
things were not clicking fnatic lost
[Music]
down the third seat from Europe a first
blow for Vietnam again I don't think I
can do this busy in Toulouse and
together we talked about how good Long's
you were how dominant they could be the
shortest game of worlds thus far the
dancing breath tale encapsulating
everything that was this game because to
me it felt like fnatic didn't even get
to play League of Legends I want you
were just one step ahead at every turn
it was a devastating start to the
tournament for a group of players who
entered groups feeling confident they
entered the second week in do-or-die
mode and in their first game against
tournament favorites Long's you gaming
things only got worse fnatic put up a
fight but were no match for long shoes
well-oiled aggression at zero and for
fnatic found themselves in a must-win
situation and they would need some help
after all no one had ever started 0 and
3 and made it out of groups let alone 0
and 4 but thanks to the Gigabyte marines
beating immortals fnatic had a chance
and in their next match against
immortals they netted a much-needed win
3d for immortals quest to run away but
fnatic they want this one the chain
sported but not quite the blade color
range and just barely missing onto that
Miami this don't want to be down to look
for the cow
grandma's gonna come in and practice we
gonna kill spreading that one his
teammate call me son loses his mind by
flashing into an entire team at the end
[Applause]
then they won their next game and thanks
to what can only be described as a
world's miracle fnatic found themselves
in a three-way tie with immortals and
the gigabyte Marines fnatic would have
to play a mini gauntlet to get out of
the group one loss would spell the end
of their time at Worlds the game against
immortals was a convincing affair then
came Viet Nam's surprisingly successful
gigabyte Marines
the thinkable and make their way to the
quarterfinals so good customers both the
truck waved away
they won the game completed an
absolutely remarkable run and secured a
berth to quarterfinals
it is a miracle no team has ever have
gone 0 and 3 in week 1 and made it you
want four straight games today to make
it caps how do you feel do you feel like
you deserve it I think the first thing I
feel is like I feel really tired at this
one it might have just been a berth to
the top eight but for a group of players
who become so accustomed to almost and
what ifs it was proof that fnatic could
compete on the international stage but
the quarterfinals against China's Royal
never give up there were another
heartbreak reckless struggling to get up
and we heard it's emotional words
emotional stories he actually said this
might be my Lost Worlds and it is to
Summerford MVP of the EU LCS who missed
the final in the US
because they want the garlic still there
world's birth had gone better than
anyone had thought was possible after
their first week of the group-stage
fnatic went home wounded but with their
heads held high of course through it all
capsules performance in the midlane
wasn't the only thing shining through so
was his big personality I am the massive
shadows are you blade the deadliest
secrets can buy weapons late Oh caps is
all business on the rift but out of game
he's almost always smiling the offseason
saw relatively few changes for the org
as they picked up another promising
rookie as a top lane sub blippo and
replaced Jess's with he'll Assange 2018
saw fnatic hit the ground running
rolling through the spring split with a
14 and 4 record earning them the first
seed heading to the playoffs
throughout the split caps had begun to
distinguish himself as more than just a
promising mid laner more than just
someone willing to pick wild off meta
champions he'd cemented himself as one
of Europe's strongest mid laners along
with perks caps had begun to ascend to
the lofty heights of Europe's great mids
I mean caps is just one of the most
exciting guys to play because he's just
so passionate he's incredibly talented
he's incredibly invested he's incredibly
emotional and when you see this guy win
or lose you get everything his
performance in the regular season earned
caps a spot on the all protein while
reckless seized season MVP fnatic
entered the playoffs confident and
hungry and this time they wouldn't let
the trophy slip through their grasp
to get to the finals and it's fair to
say that caps was confident going into
the grand finals in Copenhagen because
this caps here really tilted off you're
so angry so how is that gonna translate
onto the rift what are you gonna do to
perks in Copenhagen I'm gonna smash him
so hard that he's gonna figure this an
Asian international tournament the grand
finals wound up being a one-sided affair
international event as caps max perks oh
my word
it was Kappas first domestic title and
would earn him a spot at MSI
[Applause]
the midseason Invitational was the first
test for this revamp fnatic roster on
the world stage and they came up
somewhat wanting so much of MSI we
played for them but the criticisms went
team wide cap set it down they're
reckless a down tournament they turn it
around when they need to orangey have to
feel good about finding that win they
looked good in their wins it wasn't
perfectly clean but at the same time
their teamfight execution their ability
to stall out and play to win conditions
was well demonstrated still the
tournament was further proof that caps
could compete with the world's best
summer split was a turbulent time for
fnatic
with wreckless choosing to bench himself
for much of the mage heavy meta with
whipple playing alongside Hill assange
in the vault lane fnatic relied on Capps
to be their primary carry a contrast to
their 2017 style I think we were very
set on a style but we just had Cameron
bottling in 2017 which obviously made
this so that I didn't have the resources
to to perform as inspirational wants to
be but like next year we start playing
more round miss and I got to to show
what I can do as well and he didn't let
them down from dominating performances
on meta champions now ignited he's gonna
get burned to death on the left of your
screen Smitty Jake picks up a kill under
the tower
here comes Capps
party everybody's invited and for the
time being everybody's going to die it's
a double for cap so as picks up his
third of the fight to his classic
unorthodox choices the statement before
that caps can play everything I did not
expect a mid lane fame to be a thing
that's crazy
caps picked up summer split MVP and
fnatic cruised into a playoff run that
felt inevitable and in Barcelona they
claim to their second EU LCS title
earning themselves a world's berth the
team plays around and he is the star
player on fnatic it's not reckless it is
really all about caps and because his
performance at MSI especially in the
group stage was so so strong and in my
opinion was the best out of the mid
laners I'm not scared that he can't
perform against international players
which is always one of the big questions
when you have a a hyped up Western
player fnatic enter Worlds confident
that they could escape their group in
first place and they got off to a good
start this kind of hurts
rrett are a little more than it does
breakfast because in the 1 vs. 1
yes great stun caps looking for it does
put the manga did push food that's a
solo kill cap does it in style they hit
a bit of a snag against Invictus gaming
but they kept it together and won every
other group stage game they played
including a rematch against Invictus
gaming that forced a tiebreaker for
first place in their group and though it
was close
fnatic pulled it off triple kill perhaps
fanatics quarterfinal opponents were
Edward gaming a team that had shown some
promise in groups but which most
analysts thought fnatic could overcome
they did queueing up a historic
semi-final bout against cloud 9
guaranteeing a Western team in the grand
finals for the first time since season 1
given the caliber of opponents both
clownin and fnatic had defeated it looks
set to be a close back and forth series
it was anything but 5v3 and the last
hope for the West will be fnatic that
came to the West pickings of Europe it's
gonna be fnatic looking to knock it out
of the five feet three to get those last
few kills a desperate engaged in a
shutdown on the cap a few more second
spot but look at the play color it's
everyone dead fnatic are the game to the
west and they will represent
fanatic swept cloud9 in a match that
cemented them as the greatest Western
team at the tournament
and one super fan in particular was very
proud to have seen it cap says dad
welcome there we go so your son is
having a bit of trouble realizing it he
wants to stay calm what can you say
about the fact that he's made it to the
final so wow it's a EU made to finance
and this first time ever I don't have
all the histories but I know that this
is amazing and he played actually so
damn well so I could kick the pole so
yeah you're so good on the other side of
the bracket Invictus gaming had defeated
tournament favorites kt rolster in a
shocking five-game series then similarly
dispatched their semi-final foes g2 3 to
0 to underdogs
neither of them korean in a grand final
for the first time since korea got a
server in 2012
neither of them were expected to make it
this far but both were ready to make
history this is the best chance I'll
ever get now that I'm here I feel like I
had wanted more than ever and I don't
think IG has the same sort of fire that
really but in game 1 it was clear that
this was not the same Invictus gaming
that caps and fnatic had defeated in
groups and they will push now onto both
vexes turrets on the Nexus itself and
they will lead this series 1o
and games two and three didn't go any
better he can run away but the Nexus can
not be brought down the LPL has never
won before but that will change today
the crownless are finally king gaming on
your 2018 world champions it was a
devastating loss that few had expected
to be as one-sided as it was history for
China but heartbreak for Europe
it hit fnatic hard but they returned to
Europe as the most successful Western
team in modern League of Legends history
still caps has trouble giving that
finals a positive spin yes I feel like I
always fun like that's not one winner
right and no one else loses so in that
sense it doesn't mean that much to me
because I am their last right and the
only thing it means to me is that we
prove that we can't beat anyone and it
gives us more confidence and sense that
we believe even more that we can beat
everyone next time we play
internationally but in terms of like
accomplishment I feel like we lost you
know caps for his part has ascended he
climbed not just to the upper echelon of
Europe's famous mid laners he made a
case for himself as the greatest among
them perhaps the greatest ever from
Europe but he'd also decided it was time
for a change
[Music]
[Music]
Saosin for loves teams and my party to
look the most interesting i feel like
that playstyle is very like its they
play the same way that I wanna play they
would like a very aggressive mindset and
they are okay with making mistakes as
long as that I CRO active with perks
swapping to ad carry and perhaps the
wildest trade in Europe's history caps
will not be wearing a fanatic jersey in
2019 the move from fnatic to G to the
fact that perks is going to hate it
carry
it's a bold one but in his own words he
doesn't want to be comfortably because
when we complacent he's going for the
big move he's going for the risky play
just like his gameplay on the rift he's
making decisions about his team's and
time will tell if a zone caps is young
but decorated inexperienced but seasoned
he's a big personality but his
reputation is starting to outgrow him
he's a mechanical prodigy in the grand
tradition of the game's greatest stars
and like those that came before him caps
has proven himself on the game's biggest
stages early in his career he's face
down legends defeated some and been
swatted aside by others the caps a story
is far from closed his first two years
in Europe have given the West's hope
they can compete on the world stage
they've given him two domestic titles
but his best years may well be ahead of
him and through it all he's kept on
smiling
[Applause]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]